[ APPLAUSE ]
>> CHRIS: IT'S TIME FOR "TONGUE
TIED."
NOW YESTERDAY WAS INTERNATIONAL
TONGUE TWISTER DAY, THE FAKE
HOLIDAY WHEN WE CELEBRATE THOSE
CLASSIC PHRASES THAT CHALLENGE
YOUR ARTICULATION SKILLS AND
IMPROVE CUNNILINGUS.
THE PROBLEM IS, THOUGH, THAT NO
ONE'S WRITTEN A NEW TONGUE
TWISTER SINCE THE DAYS WHEN YOU
COULD MAKE A LIVING SELLING
SEASHELLS BY THE SEA SHORE. WHO
CARES ABOUT PICKING PECKS OF
PICKLED PEPPERS WHEN WE'VE GOT
"MONSANTO MANUFACTURING MUTANT
MIND-CONTROL MELONS"?
SO COMEDIANS, I WANT YOU TO GIFT
US WITH SOME MORE MODERN TONGUE
TWISTERS IN 60 SECONDS AND
BEGIN.
>> FLAVA FLAV GAVE DAVE COULIER
AIDS IN A PARADE.
[LAUGHING]
>> CHRIS: INSTANT CLASSIC,
POINTS.
JUDAH.
>> HEY, LOSERS AND YOUTUBERS,
HANS GRUBER'S UBER'S ARRIVED.
>> BRADLEY COOPER DROVE HIS
SUPER DUPER MINI COOPER INTO MY
POOPER.
>> CHRIS CHRISTIE CAN'T QUIT
CRYING IN QUIZNOS.
>> JESSE JACKSON JERKED OFF A
JEALOUS JACKALOPE.
>> AT HOBBY LOBBY BOBBY JINDAL'S
KINDLE DWINDLED.
>> GUY FIERI'S BLOODY MARY'S NOT
AS HAIRY AS CHAZZ PALMINTERI.